[Music]
some of my favorite interviews of women
colada that's good know and I watched
the movie last night I was really I mean
I was surprised on some level of how
much action-packed isn't even really
like doing it justice and to put that in
a World War two film yeah sometimes you
might think it you might to shoehorn it
in but in this case it really that's
what happened that's the story it's
crazy and I wanted to know about you
know what did you guys do to prepare to
really be in dogfights cuz it looks like
you really are I'm fly I mean I mean I
think we didn't really do much flying
but you know they set it up they had
planes on gimbals and wind machines and
things like that so it kind of gave you
the feeling of like you were flying we
did some simulator tests here in Pearl
Harbor which we both did good and we
both London yeah we like them yeah we
took off and we landed so you know if a
plane is going down me and Ed we got
your back yeah so yeah so it was all I
mean you know they set it up for us but
I think mainly it was getting into the
characters and kind of just watching the
old footage of the war
my character wrote a book called the
flying guns which was a huge piece of
information for me so I could hear his
voice and just kind of understand where
his mindset was because he wrote it not
long after the the war happened so yeah
man we also got to spend time in the
Pacific Aviation Museum on Ford Island
you know rod Bankston who showed me
around was just incredibly informative
and generous with his energy and it was
such an eloquent intelligent
knowledgeable person on a subject matter
and you know the moment I laid eyes on a
Douglas destroyer I was just like I said
to him that's my plane isn't it that's
that's the one of a fly and he's like
yeah I was like can I get in it he's
like let's go we went under the red tape
climbed up the wing you know sat inside
the the cockpit and I was speechless
anyone who knows me knows that's a rare
occasion and I was profound and so
informative you know and the planes that
we
were in they were exact replicas 80% of
the size for exactly replicas other than
that is scaled so it was it was amazing
you know and I do go head over heels
with my preparation anyone that's ever
work with me knows this I met my match
with with Lou client and he really was
very informative on this he gave me the
clamorous Dickinson book in 1940 edition
signed by the owner in 1941 it was an
incredible piece of history and a
beautiful thing and incredibly
informative and you know it's just
speaking to row and how the pains he
took to be historically accurate was
there ever a time where you got got a
little you know nervous or were worried
that am I gonna be portraying these you
know storied war heroes correctly or did
you not I think nervous no but but
however we did feel the sense of
responsibility and duty the whole way
through so we kind of on the edge of
that feeling uh you know very conscious
of it you know as much as we had fun and
we were messing around it was a serious
serious business and a serious shoot
with them with it important you know we
had to it was important we paid respect
yeah but I mean even to that you know
we're all playing real characters but in
this movie we can't show every character
that was an actual dive bomber that was
involved in the war so we tried to
represent everybody no to that yeah they
got it right for sure